gerri State Hillary Clinton's private
email server was reportedly hacked by
another foreign entity that issue had
been raised before but now looks like we
have some confirmation it was a Chinese
owned company they inserted code that
forwarded Clinton's emails to them in
real time that according to the Daily
Caller News Foundation even worse the
FBI was reportedly warned about this by
the Intel community's Inspector General
but did nothing in response here with
his reaction is investigative journalist
Peter Schweitzer Peter this doesn't come
as any surprise to any of us would
follow this issue there is no security
on this private email server classified
information clearly on it what is your
takeaway apparently no Russia but yes
China yeah Laura this is a huge story
and I'll tell you why think about this
for a second if this story is true and
the reporter that broke this story mr.
[ __ ] is an excellent reporter if this
story is true it means that the only
sets of all of Hillary Clinton's emails
the Secretary of State resides in
Beijing China because remember she
deleted 30,000 emails and never turned
them over to the FBI if you think about
the steel dossier the concern that was
always raised about that fake dossier
was that it would lead to a blackmail on
Donald Trump these emails would be a
massive blackmail tool for the Chinese
against Hillary Clinton those 30,000
deleted emails were personal emails they
were probably very sensitive that's why
they were deleted in the first place you
have the existing set of the other
30,000 this is a huge story and the fact
that this information was discovered
then turned over to the FBI and the FBI
counterintelligence office including mr.
Peter struck apparently took no interest
in it is shocking you know China is the
big threat here they are the rising
power challenging the United States
Russia's the declining power if I were
looking at a intelligence threat the
number one threat would be China that's
what this FBI director
today is saying China's the one we're
worried about but there was no interest
in this apparently by mr. struck and
others it's a shocking story yeah Peter
I think you reported that on this at the
time I believe when this email server
was discovered it also came out I
believe that the person in charge of
Hillary's security on her system was
told we might have had some intrusions
in the system and kind of blew off the
concern I got to go back to get the
actual language so I get it
verbatim but that was reported that he I
guess to investigators he said that will
wit there was a concern raised but
basically he was shut down when he
raised this that period that's exactly
that's exactly right the service that
that was taking care of the servers
raised this with the Clinton people and
it was dismissed because they didn't
want attention focused on the even
existence of the server so the way they
tried to cope with this was pretending
that the server wasn't there this is a
massive breach and look we were told in
the 2016 campaign that Hillary Clinton
was the adult she's the professional
she's the diplomat that knows how to get
things done and to do things in an
orderly way this thing was a massive
failure yeah well she knows how to get
things done to cover up for the Clintons
and Clinton Foundation I guess but get
things done for the American people she
got a lot done for China and I say thank
God
Hillary Clinton wasn't elected given the
fact that if this story is true
China has a treasure trove of
information which I don't think is just
about her daughter's wedding or her
grandkids or whatever yoga class there I
don't think the Chinese care about you
know the down dog and Hillary I think
they're interested in some other issues
yeah no that's that's exactly right and
and the bottom line here is I think if
you gave any counterintelligence
official a choice between being
concerned about a discredited dossier or
being concerned that you're President of
the United States has 60,000 emails in
the possession of an enemy power and you
don't even know what's in 30,000 of them
I think they would view that as a much
larger counterintelligence threat
than anything that's raised by the
dossier that's why this is she needs to
be reinvestigated and looked at it's a
counterintelligence issue and should do
should should convene an investigation a
real serious investigation just into
this issue alone frankly Peter great to
have you on tonight thank you so much